okay so
uh in that video there's four points of
Yong Yong clashing so I'll introduce
those four points and then show how we
don't do that again when we comes to non
contestation uh you have to do that 90°
fluctuation to the inertia and that
means that you're going to have to do a
spiral okay that's when you do a spiral
you will be at a constant 90°
fluctuation to the given inertia so we
have okay and the first uh
contestation
was
here
okay that is a
pull come around and you step out and
you pull
so demonstrate the two the energy first
the pulling of the
energy about your size there
[Music]
there that's a greater mass do you see
he that might want to go out to the side
doesn't
matter
[Music]
or goes into you they never go into each
other in in chiba's organization because
of the
choreography
so he'll pull me and they kind of go
here and stop they stop themselves okay
this this
goes put your foot here and this goes
[Music]
here step out don't you remember this
stuff there you go more to the side cuz
there's people who are going to say oh
if I go out to the side I'm not pulling
you are pulling so I want you to
do icate what they're
doing there you go you don't pull here
pull
here then you have your arms remember
that remember that
okay
[Music]
good it's not going to do
anything okay what we do instead
is keep the ten con work on the
elbow so this elbow is the one I
want
war this
way that's one way of doing
it off to the side Energy's coming at me
projected back
but a better
way is to just let it go around you
[Music]
then you don't have to push his elbow
which is the second
contestation so I don't want to push his
elbow so you don't
don't push
it step
in let it go around you
go around
you then you use this hand to help it go
around you
[Music]
okay let's try
that all right next is what am I doing
in the transitional
pin here
okay so what I'm going to do is an
adhesion okay there's no I'm not pinning
him I'm not I'm not pushing him down nor
am I continually trying to push him off
balance once you got him here you're in
place with the adhes
let's say uh he wants to stand up okay
so he's here and when he goes to stand
up it makes him go off balance
okay so we're not here and
then continually shoving him
down we already brought
him and I'm here in the
adhesion okay and that's where I do the
transition around me into the body
adhesion and that keeps the transition
viable okay we'll do that transition the
next condensation point
is in the pain compliance s here okay so
instead of doing
that get the Shoulder to move with the
projection so this I'm in the body and I
move in the body into that
shoulder okay and so I'm moving his
body not Twi tting and he moves his body
to take that pain
off I'm moving his body this is
effortless so we're
here and he's going to twist to hurt me
and you'll see this L time in here okay
that's telling you it's didn't travel up
the joints and then the UK goes back he
okay so he's there and this is dependent
upon his ability to keep that Integrity
you see you okay so it's a strength move
I'm out okay so we don't want to stress
our grip which you will when you seek to
overpower the person instead you go into
the
body it's in the
body in the
body and I stay with his grip okay let's
add
that so that's a wrist twist
what you're doing is a kind of you want
to do a nag waza so projector
Center
not break her
wrist feel for her Center in this
movement if you focus your energy into
the wrist which you will if you focus
your Technique in the twisting and the
strength of your
grip you want to come up her arm feel
her center from there move that that's
better okay so try
it we'll just get to that
last okay so I don't want all this play
in that elbow in that shoulder or in
this wrist so from here I move that in a
unified man and there's not much wrist
twist right okay but she moves
immediately as opposed to they slack
slack slack disjointed you see so
immediately I start
working that angle and I throw the
center
box requiring no twisting of my hand
okay but if she tries to twist the other
way oh it's going to go right into that
wrist but it's very impossible to get
your Center back you're going to have to
shift levels and that's where we're
going from here okay try to all right
the next contention point is on the
final
pin and they go here and you're pushing
down on that so you're like I'm going to
take him over here no you're freaking
not okay you're not okay so we have to
not adopt that linear
contestation
angle and instead continue to use the
spiral so he's going to go
down and this hand's not pushing down
but keeping the spiral going and he will
eventually see where he could fall
which makes my elbow control exactly
that elbow
control not push
down okay it's not shoving
down then you have the pig all right TR
[Music]